there's all these rumors unfounded that  ron desantis ordered the raid on trump's  mar-a-lago because he's governor of  florida mar-a-lago is in florida  desantis is angling for the 2024  republican nomination and so he wants to  do something that will hurt trump i  think it's not plausible for two reasons  number one i just don't believe the fbi  is going to be bossed around by a  governor at the end of the day we're  talking about a federal agency here and  number two i actually don't know that  it's that bad for trump that he got  raided it actually might fire up a lot  of his followers but the most important  thing is desantis's reaction has not  been indicative of a guy who's happy  about it now maybe he is but there's no  evidence desantis reacting by saying  this is the weaponization of law  enforcement type of thing  people are going overboard so conspiracy  theory for now that desantis ordered it  i don't think it's plausible there's no  evidence of it whatsoever